advice from dub Charney on finding your  passion passion that's it when you  believe in what you're doing that's it I  think I was born a hustler I like the  hustle I like selling a product that  people love I knew I could do it  differently and I knew I could turn it  around and I knew there was a solution  and there was no way that kind of  passion or can-do spirit I said there's  no way I'm stopping now when you believe  in what you're doing that's the first  thing and you have to be resilient  because people are going to try to knock  you down anything we want to do we can  do if we can dream it it can be done to  learn more check out zucca 101 find your  passion in the link below